right so let me begin by taking you back
in time so the time is now ten past five
on the 28th of December 1970 I see sheep
and in the skies above Portland Oregon
there is a dc-8 that's flown from Denver
and is just coming in to land at
Portland International Airport there are
a hundred and eighty-nine souls on board
so as they're coming into land they
start to lower the undercarriage and
when they do there's a big loud thump
it's something that they can hear even
feel in the cockpit that whole aircraft
shakes so it's not much of a surprise
when Portland approached tell them to
continue their descent and they say no
no no we're going we're going to go back
up to 5,000 feet and we're going to
circle for a while because we've got a
landing gear problem landing gear
problems aren't a big deal for a big
commercial jet they they can land
without any undercarriage at all they
can land with only half their
undercarriage this is fairly normal for
a actually a surprising number of
landing gear failures that happen every
year believe it or not you they don't
make the news because nothing
interesting happens nobody dies so it's
a huge surprise when after some fairly
regular ordinary radio traffic from
United 173 Portland hear this one
Portland Tower United 173 heavy Mayday
where the engines are flaming out we're
going down we're not going to be able to
make the airport and just a few seconds
later they impact power lines near
northeast 150 8th Avenue
and East Burnside Street that's downtown
Portland very close to the real-time
compote L actually that's what it ended
up looking like and amazingly only ten
people died
although 24 seriously injured most of
that was because they hit a tree and it
was luckily a small wooded area in the
middle of housing so they were very
lucky and in fact there was a rescue
team airborne on an exercise when they
hit the ground so this is air crashes
just in case you got confused and
thought that last picture was a
recursive makefile or something I home
Dave Cridland and I've been working in
and around the internet for an
embarrassingly long time now so long
that I can even remember when Google was
an open standards company I worked for a
company called Shore vine my colleague
Lloyd also just over there also speaking
works with us as well and we do sort of
social stuff on the web for people who
really care about security so when I got
into air crashes or reading them and
reading the reports this was way before
they were all on the web which they are
now it's great and they have pretty
animations to tell you what happened but
I got into them because a company I
worked for about 15 years ago the CEO
there would hand you aircraft crash
reports and saying just read this one
it's great and I would say well why do I
care about that because I don't do
anything with our craft I work with
software and these say well yeah but
aircraft are large complex systems of
interacting components and so's software
so it's a software that we built which
was incidentally server-side javascript
it'll never take off
and the kinds of the kinds of errors
that you get oh sorry
skipped a bit and what we do to avoid
errors is we deal in redundancy and
decoupling and that's the same with
aircraft as well so the failure cases
that we get are typically complex error
chains they call them Aero chains in
aviation we tend to call in cascade
failures same thing and even the name
that we use for a serious failure is the
same and with aircraft every time an
aircraft does not function as it should
then there is a detailed investigation
analyzing every cause in all possible
recommendations afterwards it's not
quite the same in software
so I've read I've read dozens of
accident reports and summaries and
actually I'm still not scared of flying
I took two flights to get here had to
change at Schiphol
it's my airport of choice for changing
for some reason there's only two
accident reports that actually really
leave me feeling quite scared about
about everything out of curiosity how
many people flew here that's great how
many people are thinking of flying back
okay
we'll change that during so what
happened with United 173 why on earth
did that plane crash so this might give
you a hint just a small one so when it
took off from Denver Colorado it had
forty six thousand seven hundred pounds
of fuel they like their Imperial
measurements now when it was on the the
approach to Portland we can estimate
very accurately from its flight plan
from how it actually flew we can we can
be pretty sure it had about fourteen
thousand eight hundred pounds of fuel
left we know that because it's
undercarriage was down the flaps were
down it was circling at five thousand
feet we know that that all of that is
not very optimal so we know that it's
burning about 220 pounds a minute and
that's borne out by the flight engineer
report at about seventeen thirty eight
and the flight engineer is a third a
third flight crew member they're not
nothing to have them on modern aircraft
naturally he sits behind the pilots he's
got a bank of instruments in front of
him he's got the full readouts of
everything the the two pilots the
captain in the first officer they've
only got the headline figure so they're
kind of so in order to check exactly how
much fuel you've got you tend to ask the
flight engineer but nevertheless they've
got a headline by 1746 they've got 5,000
and the flight engineer is reporting
this to the first
who's at this point the pilot flying
while the captain is sorting out
problems and the the pilot the pilot in
charge the captain in normal speak tells
the flight engineer to prepare for a
landing with 4000 pounds of fuel and you
can see that's only that's five minutes
after he had five thousand there's
something wrong here the first officer
requests a fuel check again at seventeen
fifty five he's told four thousand the
the captain then tells Portland we're
gonna land with about four thousand well
make it three thousand pounds of fuel
this is clearly not right six minutes
past six and the flight the first
officer tells the captain we're going to
lose an engine buddy and the captain
says why he says fuel well activate the
cross feeds so they activate the cross
feeds to shuffle fuel between tanks and
then they think it's a good idea to ask
for a landing clearance a minute later a
couple of minutes later the the flight
engineer is reporting only a thousand
pounds of fuel and then Mayday is
declared at 1813 with the engines pretty
much all running out
the report basically said this accident
exemplifies a recurring problem with
management of crew resources and this
was an odd phrase to use and the blame
was assigned purely to the captain who
was stripped of his pilot's license and
as far as I know never never recovered
never flew again and the contributing
factor was given his crew failure so
they're not saying the landing gear was
problem they're not saying the fuel was
a problem they're saying this is a crew
problem this is rather unfortunate as
the flight engineering question Forrest
frosty Mendenhall was one of those
killed an impact it's probably going to
relate it to the other crashes which
this is referring to it's sent as a top
aircraft safety tip does anyone know
where the safest place to sit in an
aircraft is because it turns out that
it's the passenger seats if your crew
your odds aren't good when you hit it
when you hit a crash you're much more
likely to die be your passenger it's
much better
so the related crashes which were all
very very similar there's a 1963 triple
off 124 crash into the neva river what
happened was there was a landing gear
problem on takeoff in fact they can
retract it properly so they decided they
would circle around to use up fuel as in
the days before aircraft tended to dump
it and they simply looped too many times
ran out of fuel landed in the Neva River
with amazingly no casualties they didn't
even have actuate the aircraft they just
towed it it's great 1969 Scandinavian 93
a landing gear problem they failed to
watch the altitude crashed short of the
runway 15 people killed 1972 Eastern 401
very famous crash for aviation crash
buffs like me landing a problem they
disengage the autopilot by accident
causing
99 fatality is when they crashed into
the Everglades and then the big one the
Tenerife Airport disaster so we're now
back to the 27th of March 1977
I'd never heard properly the opening
lines to others knowing me knowing you
before but they seem particularly
poignant for this all the songs by the
way were number one at the time that at
the time in question so it's about six
o'clock in evening and we're at an
airport called La Strada us in Tenerife
and the airport name is now changed by
the way to Tenerife North what you find
is that flight numbers tend to get put
out of service when there's a big crash
on them and it turns out that they do
this they did this with this Airport as
well in fact they built a whole new
airport this is a cascade failure it's a
chain of errors leading to a final a
final fatal disaster it starts off with
a bomb that explodes in Las Palmas the
airport and Gran Canaria and it was
actually done by Canary Islands
separatists protesting against the
Franco regime which was just still in at
that point
frankly I she dies later that year and
there was another bomb warning given
although there wasn't in fact another
bomb so they closed the airport and
diverted everything in flight to Los
rodeos she's a much much smaller Airport
los Reina Ross Los Rios has an
interesting problem it's a relatively
high altitude an airfield it's a 2,000
feet or about 600 meters so it has a
problem with Denslow Claire it
occasionally sweeping across the airport
and it had this at the time they also
had an unusual amount of traffic
normally they wouldn't see very much
international traffic now their entire
Airport is full the two aircraft in
question are the KLM flight 4805 with
248 people on and Pan Am 17:36 with
nearly 400 people on these both Boeing
747s they've both flown internationally
so and I for attributions sake I pulled
this bull this diagram off Wikipedia and
adjusted it to fit but this is this is
basically what happened the KLM flight
was was first leaning you to take off in
effect it was blocking all of the others
the apron there that's where the
aircraft park
it's where the terminals are things like
that that was completely jammed full of
aircraft so they couldn't use the normal
taxiway that you that you see that runs
across the across the top there so the
KLM flight is first to take off does
what's known as a back taxi it runs down
to the end of the runway turns around
and is ready to go and the Pan Am
follows it fairly quickly afterwards
with the intent of turning off once they
got past the apron and they're a little
confused about which taxiway to use the
dense fog is really not helping them at
this point and there they're told when
they ask for clarification to use the
third one so one two three third one for
whatever reason though you can see the
Pan Am misses the third one it's clear
from the voice transcripts that they
actually didn't have a clue where they
were on the runway and but that's okay
because the control tower knows that
they're still on the runway so we're
fine the KLM flight piloted by a very
experienced captain called Franz Anton
he was actually their chief instructor
at the time and yeah and she gets to the
end he gets lined up and he starts
moving the throttles forward and his
first officers wait a minute we don't
have agency clearance that's air traffic
control clearance which you get before
takeoff clearance by the way so he says
to where to go ahead and ask and so they
they ask the tower gives them the
clearance ATC clearance this is not
takeoff clearance and so they repeat the
instructions back and now what happens
is something that's really quite
seriously horrible because the tower
responds with okay
and what you're seeing there is the the
normal type is what both aircraft and
here due to radio interference though
only Pan Am can hear the stuff in
italics except you guys probably don't
call it italics you call it M or
something but so they hear the KLM
flight simply hears okay which is
non-standard but whatever they don't
hear stand by for takeoff I will call
you they don't hear the Pan Am response
of no and we're still taxiing down the
runway the Clipper 173 six they do both
here our pepper alpha one seven three
six report the runway clear I don't know
whether the KLM crew thought that this
meant that they had reported the runway
clear that the tower was reporting the
runway clear tower never calls to Pan Am
flight Packer alpha at any time other
than this one message so it could be
confusing
either way they put forward the engines
there's as they start to roll the flight
engineer says the American he's cleared
them and gets a very definitive yeah Val
from the captain and possibly the first
office of the transcripts very unclear
yeah well by the way for those of you
who don't speak Dutch means absolutely
so they're rolling down the runway
clearly the flight engineer is a bit
worried but the captain's overruled in
the Pan Am flight they can't see each
other remember we got dense cloud
suddenly they start to see the lights
wobbling kind of down the runway and he
says there he is go down that son of a
[ __ ] is coming so they try and pull the
Pan Am flight off they turn it engines
on full and a rather unusual maneuver in
a 747 then I meant a corner that fast
and tries to get into to the exit for as
the KLM flight rolls down
they call v1 which is the point if you
if you've been in an aircraft that was a
stupid thing just now as you're rolling
down you know at that point where the
aircraft is now running fast enough that
they can tip back to what they call the
rotate that's that's v1 so they're there
at v1 at this point that means that they
their nose is pointed out which means
that they can no longer see the runway
as clearly but they still can see it and
the captain sees the Pan Am flight at
the last minute and he pulls back even
harder causing what's called a tail
strike where the rear of the aircraft
tail ends up and ends up striking the
runway and it gauged a big hole in it in
fact and he manages to get it just about
airborne but the KLM flight is full of
fuel they refueled before departure at
Los rodeos and it cannot quite clear the
Pan Am flight so you get this this
impact and this is what the the CVR
transcript says just exclamation
expletive that's actually the last that
anyone will hear from the KLM flight it
impacts more or less breaking apart all
the way down the runway
everyone's killed on that pretty much
instantly and the fact that it's full of
fuel just means that the for fire is
pretty horrific the the fire crew at Los
rodeos immediately head to the KLM
flight but even they aren't aware that
there are two aircraft on the runway and
they mistake the Pan Am flight initially
for just another piece of burning
wreckage when they eventually get there
61 survivors have escaped by themselves
and 335 people are still sitting in the
aircraft patiently waiting what to do a
top tip when you get in a plane by the
way is listen to the safety briefing
plan your exit it may come as a surprise
that you need to use it so the so the
airline industry started using
they call crew resource management which
is a doctrine where everyone in the crew
maintains situational awareness knowing
what's going on knowing that there is
another plane knowing that the fuel is
running low all of this information must
be shared in the team planning and
decision-making should be shared
although you have a single leader who
makes the ultimate decision they need to
make sure that everyone has voiced their
objections to possible objections and
opinions on the plan communications both
inside the cockpit and outside a vehicle
or inside and outside the team if you
like and good teamwork by which I mean
that everyone gets on with the specific
tasks they need to rather than trying to
get everyone to do the same task this
isn't really a leadership talk in fact
this is mostly a talk about lots of
people dying hideous deaths but it
wouldn't be a leadership talk even if I
was only talking about crew resource
management because leading people is
just one person's job and effective
teamwork is everybody's job the entire
team needs to be involved so crew
resource management was taken on by
United in particular in 1980 following
various talks by NASA it turns out that
they had been using in their Apollo
program and it was thought that this was
going to help minimize crew problems
crew failures as the NTSB report put it
in the future so what happens if a if a
crew faces what would normally be an
unsurvivable incident but they've got
excellent crew resource management
so this would be United 232
on the 19th of July 1999 at just after
quarter past three in the afternoon near
Sioux City Iowa a dc-10 that's a
three-engined
airliner significance of which will
become apparent in a minute was flying
from Denver to Chicago with 296 souls on
board an unusual number of these were
children because it happened to be
United's Children's Day special and it
just after quarter past three after an
uneventful climb to altitude the rear
central engine blew the fan the main
turbine disc in fact shattered into
several pieces and the pieces went
through the tailplane assembly what that
left United united 232 with was two
problems firstly the aircraft had a
marked tendency because of the damage to
turn to the right left alone it would
simply flip itself over completely you
don't want to do that in a in a jetliner
however that on its own is not a major
problem because you've got the aircraft
controls to compensate move it back on
track so this would only be a serious
problem if they'd lost all the
hydraulics which they had because all
three hydraulic systems were made
inoperative each hydraulic system is
driven by an engine obviously they'd
lost their number two engine so they'd
lost number two hydraulics but they had
punctured lines for one and three and
all of the hydraulic fluid has simply
drained out of the system so the flight
engineer
Godley Dvorak on the radio in fact two
United maintenance says this is united
232 we blue number two engine
we've lost all hydraulics and we're only
able to control a level flight with the
asymmetric power settings we have very
little rudder or elevator fact they had
no rudder or elevator or ailerons or
claps or speed breaks or even the little
breaks on the wheels to slow them down
it should they ever land and the
maintenance then had a really
interesting interesting and amusing
conversation which basically went
something along the lines of oh you've
you've lost number two hydraulics but
you still got one in three right no no
we've lost all three
oh you've lost number three oh that's
okay you still got one and two right it
took them a long time to realize that
what they'd done was lost them all
this was calculated as being a ten to
the nine to one
it's 1 billion to one chance and so the
United have checklists for all
eventualities except this one it's
deemed impossible and it's deemed
unsurvivable the captain al Hanes saying
okay we're trying to go straight but
we're not having much luck the crew
immediately sorted out the engine
problem itself the initial problem they
shot down the engine within 14 seconds
it was then that they realized that the
plane wasn't reacting and they started
talking all through themselves about
every single operation they were doing
they decided they would continue using
the controls just in case it was having
any effect and pretty much everything
that this crew talks through everything
that this crew has to do is talk through
as an entire team before they make a
decision our Hanes maintaining a sense
of humor we didn't do this thing on my
last performance chair and then
something really quite remarkable
happens this is real Hollywood moment
one of the passengers comes up to help
now al just introduces himself my name
is our Haynes and the passenger
introduces himself Hideout Denny Fitch
Denny Fitch has been working for the
last of three or four weeks or so as
United's dc-10 flight instructor he is
the one person that you really want in
the cockpit and this is in part because
he's familiar with another crash
Japan Airlines one two three now if a
Tenerife air disaster is the most
serious aviation disaster ever and it is
then this is the most serious single
incident air disaster ever it's the 12th
of August 1985 it's just after six
o'clock in the evening it's beginning to
go dark the plane took off from take a
Tokyo Japan was claiming to altitude by
the way it's a 747 short-range variant
which carries extra people which is a
tragedy in itself that should happen to
this aircraft so as they as they flew up
to altitude a bad repair to an aft
bulkhead caused by a tail strike several
years ago caused an explosive
decompression and I shall use my laser
pointer at this point can you see there
there's a bit missing on this plane the
entire vertical stabilizer has got blown
off and that has taken out all of their
hydraulics they've got total hydraulic
lost just like United 232 and they
managed thirty five minutes of flight
time very in a very very unstable
aircraft because they were not only
missing control surface control they
were missing large chunks of the
aircraft they ended up crashing in a
remote mountainous area very late one
evening initial reports suggested no
survivors they've got a helicopter over
there when they found it and one of the
four survivors who they found the next
morning I said that she heard the the
helicopter circling could see the lights
and the helicopter flew off and over the
course of the night all the moaning from
the other survivors also faded to
nothing as you might guess this is the
other one that really freaks me out so
back to United 232 I'm looking really
really shaky on time but we'll gather
oh that's all right in that case I'll
take a juice so you did 232 i'll
Haines's in no illusions about how
survivable this event is he's here he's
talking to the to the cabin crew lead
can't remember the name of this terrible
and and she's talking about whether or
not they're going to evacuate the plane
and he says look I mean if if we're
standing up at the front and will tell
you to evacuate but I I really had my
doubts you'll see a standing out honey
he also comments of won't this be a fun
landing as I say the aircrew talk about
about every decision and one of the
decisions that they talk about is well
is how and whether to lower the landing
gear as I said a beginning of this talk
an aircraft can land without any landing
gear at all if you're landing on a soft
surface that's actually preferable
because otherwise the end of the landing
gear will sink into the surface and it
will jerk and break off and it will
likely cause more damage and they
decided unanimously very going to lower
the undercarriage but that turned out to
be two mechanisms for doing so so they
discuss it through and they decide to
crank the undercarriage down which will
release the outer airlock outer ailerons
potentially releasing some extra
hydraulic fluid that they may get some
controlling to so they get closer and
closer to Cu City Airport
under the very excellent guidance of a
guy called Kevin Bachman who's a he's a
flight controller who actually moved to
Cu city because he was at a busier
Airport and he didn't like the stress
he gives than a weather readout and says
you're clear to land on any runway Al
Haynes replies with typical humor you
ought to be in particular and make it a
runway they line up for runway 22 to -
that's actually a closed runway you
cannot see the hole of the runway from
the tower it's an Old World War one
vintage runway it's also where they've
got all the emergency equipment parked
right now so they move that and they
manage to move it all out of the way
clear so as they're coming in to land
and it's it's incredible that they got
as far as an airport I should stress as
they're coming in the normal landing in
a dc-10 is 140 knots 200 feet per minute
they are now coming in at 250 knots and
increasing and 1,850 feet per minute
that's nearly ten times faster than they
should be on rate of descent I was that
going to fail see I shouldn't have
controlled it with JavaScript
so Kevin Buckman sees roughly that from
the tower and in his own words he went
down the stairs and had a little cry but
amazingly there were survivors
although 112 or killed or 111 according
to the official report there's a
complication with how you measure
fatalities and air crashes and but 111
were killed instantly 1 was killed just
after a month a third of these were due
to smoke inhalation but an amazingly 184
survived that's almost two-thirds and
there was a deadheading united captain
in first class as one of the very few
survivors from first class who actually
climbed out of the window and when told
that you can't climb out of an aircraft
window he said oh yes you can when the
flight lands you can't really see this
but it comes in the right wing tips at
the last minute and they couldn't
control this unfortunately and so the
right wing hits that tears off spills
fuel everywhere everything ignites the
tail breaks off causing the aircraft to
flip up it bounces along the runway
loses the entire cockpit assembly then
starts breaking apart the it looks like
it cartwheels in the initial news
reports say that but actually it's the
left wing flipping over so the whole
thing is now upside down the passengers
help the crew the cabin crew as much as
the cabin crew help the passengers some
cabin crew were strapped in in a full
point harness as they are and unable to
actually release themselves and one
passenger having got himself out of a
hole in the side went back in because
you had a baby cry and eventually found
the baby had been thrown into the
overhead luggage bins but if you're like
me you really want to know what happened
to the to the crew so the cockpit
wreckage was eventually found over half
an hour later it was squashed down to
waist high I've seen pictures
unfortunately no not on the internet but
it goes down to that there and this is a
part of the plane that should be 10 feet
high
they found it though because the flight
engineer David wark
had his arms stuck up through some of
the wires and things that was there so
they realized that the worms had people
inside that so he went and they found
the entire flight crew alive albeit
fairly battered and injured but all of
them alive and quite amazingly all of
the flight crew survived and returned to
work most of them within three months
Denny Fitch who is very badly injured he
was actually sitting behind operating
the throttles for them
he had nerve damage to one arm was told
he'd never fly again
but nevertheless managed to some 11
months later on dc-10 since landing 30
seconds okay that's good
so so these are quotes from a talk by Al
Haynes back to NASA in fact the NASA
Ames center and the whole talk you can
find on YouTube and it's great is that
up until 1980 we worked on the concept
that the captain was the authority on
the aircraft and what he said goes and
we lost a few airplanes because of that
and we had 103 years of flying
experience there in the cockpit trying
to get that airplane on the ground not
men were not one minute of which we had
actually practiced any one of us so if I
hadn't used CRM if we had not let
everybody put their input in it's a
cinch we wouldn't have made it the work
that we do for most of us anyway will
never involve human lives will never
involve anything like that but
nevertheless you can learn a lot from
how to do teamwork the aviation way
thanks very much
you